bonjour joan boudou président du cercle
démocratique de la martinique un parti
politique rayé il ya un peu plus de deux
ans où se situe le cercle à droite à
gauche
au mieux nous avoue n'est pas la
question
je tiens d'abord à mes sincères
condoléances à la famille de monsieur
jeanne mance et conseiller général de
cette manière et qui a également enlevé
pour le développement de l'éducation
mais aussi pour lutter contre
l'illettrisme
et aussi j'ai une pensée particulière ce
matin pour les prochains la famille très
jeune britannique est décédé dans des
conditions tragiques
ce qui nous fait dire que le bâtiment à
l'école et de la société de harcèlement
c'est un flux en tout cas qu'il faut
qu'il faut aux ou 9
attention donc nous espérons que toute
la lumière soit faite sur cette affaire
et en tout cas ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que nous sommes toujours
responsable de ce qu'on laisse faire
individuellement et collectivement époux
pas parler du siècle le siècle est un
parti qui est au dessus de tous clivages
politiques le sac s'est créé pas ce que
nous avons fait un constat que dans les
partis traditionnels
il ya un trou de 7 à l'isthme politique
c'est pour cela que des jeunes de droite
comme de gauche qui avaient
l'interdiction par le haut dit gino
l'époque de se rencontrer dans des bars
et autres ont décidé de prendre leurs
connexions vraiment oui parce que vous
dit quand on vous taper sur les doigts
si parra n'a pas marqué mais quand j'ai
pas aimé mais débat rappelez vous en
êtes responsable des jeunes de l'ump et
qu'il fallait inviter sous notable le
logo de l'ump des jeunes de gauche ou
bien deux
2009 certaines entre 4,6 et est une
complication effectivement nous avons vu
que pour que la martinique puisse
avancer également il fallait qu'il y ait
une concertation entre tous les partis
autres que toutes les idéologies vous
vraiment faire bouger les choses et cela
sert que c'est un mouvement transversal
exact nous voulons d'abord revenir tout
le monde trouver les solutions
et s'il ya pas de solution moment où on
ne l'a pas ce débat là mais le cirque en
tout cas où ni toute personne du logis
politique payante au travail et au
développement de la martinique avec une
quand même une petite caractéristiques
et joan boudou
il faut être âgé de moins de 40 ans
n'ont pas forcément le sien en grande
majorité est composée de jeunes de moins
de 40 ans mais lorsque jean noël a pas
moins de 40 ans le 10 octobre 2004
l'effective mans la composition de ce
groupe est destinée à envoyer un message
à la jeunesse martiniquaise
vous aussi vous pouvez vous aimé rester
en politique vous aussi vous avez cette
capacitéà élève le débat public alors
venez et puis le caput effet vous allez
leur proposer croit à ces jeunes de
moins de 40 ans majoritairement nous
allons proposer de militer comme le font
les partis traditionnels
chez nous il ya le militantisme il ya
surtout la la formation et la gestion
des dossiers
c'est ce que nous sommes pas un parti
comme comme les autres qui va sous le
terrain à 2 3 - 2 2 chaque élection
après deux ans d'existence nous avons
déjà au cercle on circle communaux donc
des entendants dans les communes le cers
est un mouvement martiniquais
c'est maintenant officiel étant un
simple partie communale non pas du tout
le parti qui m'a tenu que nous avons
déjà onze on se sert des communaux et
d'ailleurs en novembre nous allons
inaugurer à vis du lot
le terme annoncés donner vie au pilote
peu parce que nous avons des déjà
militant que dynamique et très motivé
alors on leur dit quoi aux membres du
cercle à ceux qui nous écoutent ce matin
par exemple de suivre les premiers
échanges dans le cadre de la primaire du
centre et de la droite ce sera en
télévision même si vous avez porté vous
personnellement individuellement
votre choix sur frédéric lefebvre qui
n'a pas été retenu pour la suite vous
inciter les jeunes à regarder ce genre
de débat avec des partis traditionnels
alors j'ai apporté mon soutien sur
frédéric lefebvre la priorité c'est que
nous sommes en capacité de recevoir tous
les candidats qui vont à la
présidentielle donc effectivement
lorsqu'on a eu contact avec vous dès que
les fèves
ça s'est fait rapidement mais tous les
autres candidats
ah parce que nous considérons qu'ils
n'ont pas de ruée les idées concrètes à
composer pour la martinique
nous les recevrons ou le redire notre
vision de la menthe et joue les
candidats pas tous les candidats tout
dépend de comment la personne s'exprime
au sujet de notre peuple de notre
territoire
on peut pas accepter n'importe quoi même
si dans un an et forte croissance recchi
par exemple dont ceux qui son prétendu
être candidat c'est présidentielle de
notre champ le cénacle acceptent
d'échanger avec toutes les personnes qui
respecte notre territoire et la société
à partir du moment où pour des raisons
électoralistes
on se permet de faire des allusions qui
met le doute de pub faut pas l'accepter
nous avons déjà eu à voyager au dessus
aujourd'hui deux exemples ben bayatt de
persuasion septembre la réaction de
fillon nous avons réagi
il ya eu aussi la réaction de nicolas
sarkozy ensuite fais à l'aise pour
parler que j'étais dans les années
passent et président du comité de
soutien
je suis ce qu'on appelle le résultat de
la de sarkozy comme nathalie on va pas
se le cacher des choses mais aujourd'hui
nous disons que c'est apporter le
respect à ce candidat de l'union qui va
contre des coûts nou camp quand quand on
est gaulois mais en même temps il disait
que aimé césaire faisait partie de ses
ancêtres
il faut que les gens pour des cons
c'était un mois alors concernant cette
présidentielle en partie de passer aux
législatives voudrez
des consignes de vote ou pas n'ont
manifestement ce sera non non non pas
parce qu'on cible mais par contre nous
appelons l'ensemble de nos militants et
de martinique a observé à écouter en
fait les propositions avec beaucoup
d'attention par ces mots il faut
vraiment pas tout tous ces débats là
avec beaucoup de sérieux et le bas juste
se mettre dans une allée ces deux
conflits personnes il faut vraiment
écouter les idées parce que c'est a
conseillé la chose pour l'interview
sincèrement alors les législatives
vous avez déjà investi au moins deux
candidats juin goudou vous dans le
centre atlantique et puis steve
louis-marie dans le sud deux investiture
surface un même parti j'enfile or dans
le sud et alfred marie jeanne qui est
actuellement dans le centre atlantique
vous allez affronter le mime a compté
c'est un grand mot parce qu'au seul
démocratique avec la politique mais au
jeu démocratique ce moment c'est là que
la différence
nous considérons que nous avons pas de
concurrent d'adversaires mais que des
partenaires alors effectivement le jeu
électoral fera que nous ferons face un
débat d'idées dans le respect des
personnes ou nous sortirons forcément
vainqueur et par la suite nous
travaillons quand même ensemble sur les
idées qui pourraient faire avancer la
martinique aujourd'hui même si nous
sommes tous ne vont pas signer de pactes
de gestion si là c'était a besoin des
compétences du cercle propos pour avoir
fait du dossier
nous répondons présents d'autres
secteurs par exemple pourriez-vous faire
des propositions à ceux qui dirigent la
septième aujourd'hui c'est un peu un
numérique
depuis un an le cirque pousse un projet
qu'on appelle le lamantin allumé kkr et
bain dans le dossier de la sema veliki
qui a été débattu que ces messieurs pas
la semaine dernière nous avons proposé
aussi que cette que cette scène soir
soit transformé en scène de régionale
des stratégies numériques alors la
proposition a été entendu puisque
puisque la maritime ne sais pas le a dit
qu'elle intègre et le numérique dans
dans la nouvelle version de la cena
ville
à quelle hauteur nous verrons nous
devons le voir esca travail tout cela
ensemble
en tout cas nous y verrons
ce dossier sur tous les plans communal
et même territoriale faut qu'enfin la
martinique soit soit dotée de ce data
centers
toute cette école numérique qui
permettrait de roy dynamiser l'économie
et de fait un rôle nous jeunes qui est
qui qui partent et qu'ils ne reviennent
plus enfin on veut notre territoire
un dernier mot puisqu'il aurait atteint
4 secondes un mot sur l'ambiance
politique de façon très globale et
générale la politique vous êtes
satisfait de ce que vous voyez en ce
moment je ne suis pas satisfait parce
que vous lui la population est en
souffrance
le milieu économique est en attente
effectivement il faut toujours un stock
de temps pour mettre en place d'une
collectivité ou du sable l'étouffant
maintenant et c'est pour ça comme comme
j j'étais juste avant si aux bisons en
tibane anti coup de main pour ebay la
montée nous là mais ne pas lui sa
population comme ça dans cette
souffrance
partir maintenant merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce matin jean goudeau appel vous
êtes le président du cercle démocratique
de la martinique mais aussi la journée